le militant pacifique martin luther king
est un héros de la lutte contre le
racisme et la pauvreté en se glissant
dans la peau du pasteur didier lucien
réalise un grand rêve je pense que pour
moi aussi c'est une vocation on y est
mais c'est un rêve concret complet et
qui
dans la lignée des choses que je voulais
faire
la pièce au sommet de la montagne
imagine martin luther king dans
l'intimité de sa chambre d'hôtel la
veille de son assassinat a même fait ce
délai si le 4 avril 1968
l'icône devient alors un simple mortel
quelque chose d'intéressant là dedans de
devoir c'est être le témoin même le
déifier paix de le ramener à c'est vrai
que dans sa chambre d'hôtel et devait
être pas loin de moi non plus
au fil d'une discussion avec une
inconnue le prix nobel de la paix se
montre vulnérables et tourmenté par ses
convictions l'autre et safran américaine
qatari al qui signe la pièce a voulu en
quelque sorte réparer le passé car sa
mère originaire de memphis avait voulu
voir le pasteur lors de son passage en
ville elle a eu ses regrets la mère de
lou triste de ne pas avoir pu le voir en
vrai et puis l'autriche a imaginé en
fait la rencontre
l'occasion ratée elle a pu les faire se
rencontrer dans dans cette pièce l'on
dit lucien écart de martin luther king
avec jenny accomplissant un tour de
force ma recherche était pas
nécessairement juste historique je
regardais beaucoup doc documentaire voir
comment ils bougeaient ensuite voir
comment moi je croyais comment je
voulais le voir bouger dans cette pièce
me
fallait prendre des décisions décision
et des décisions
[Musique]
la pièce est troublante actualité car
les mots de martin luther king sont
éternelles il s'agit d'un appel à la
réflexion mais aussi à l'action six
équipes en salle que j'ai entendu parler
mathieu qui vient voir la pièce c'est
intéressant de faire comme ça peut-être
qu'il va se met à lire bien savoir un
peu plus sur les droits civils comment
tout cela s'est passé ou est-ce qu'on en
est maintenant
au sommet de la montagne est présentée
jusqu'au 26 mars chez duceppe ici oui
fait dépouiller même radio gardes m'ont
rien
[Musique]